you know it's kind of like you draw from
all these things there isn't any one
thing it's kind of like you I consider
the the creative process to be like
you're in a dark room you can't see a
thing you're on hands and knees and you
crawl about feeling about all the things
you need are somewhere in that room and
as you as you touch the thing that
resonates with you you find it and you
pull it to you and you start bringing it
all together and I kind of feel like I
did a deep dive in so many different
ways reading I mean I reread All the
President's Men and that idea and we
watched that movie because the tone of
this being about conspiracy and like how
high does the corruption go and
Watergate and the idea that maybe Batman
and Gordon could be a little bit of
um Woodward and Bernstein like that that
that this all this kind of stuff
informed the movie and then once you've
got that it kind of goes away right so
you use all of that you it's the raw
material that inspires you you try to
make it as personal as possible and then
it just comes out the way that it comes
out